elder scrolls 4 tape 5 Tony Hawk
downhill Jam day one tape six these are
each three tapes Far Cry instincts
predator xbox360 nope
oh what soccer explained for gamers
that's good oh hey there video gamer but
world soccer finals are on right now but
you've probably been too busy playing
digital sports to notice but did you
know that soccer is a game just like
your video games
hi there I'm sports education expert
Bobby handler II and to celebrate Team
USA's qualifications to the world series
of soccer here's the sport explained in
terms you understand soccer or football
as it was released in the PAL
territories as a competitive squad base
multiplayer game played on a map roughly
100 by 50 meters in size like dota
there's only one map but team still swap
size halfway through the game teams are
made up of 11 players made up of four
squads defenders midfielders attackers
and the tank there is only one game type
and it plays out like reverse CTF except
with only one flag the flag this leather
sphere roughly 27 inches in diameter is
distribute around the map using the
player's legs head and torso teams must
work together to get the flag into the
opposing teams capture point and score
the most captures before the game ends
when a point is scored the flag is reset
to the center of the map headshots are
permitted each capture point is guarded
by the opposing teams tank his role is
to soak up damage from the opposition
flag carriers and distribute the flag
back to a squad he is allowed to use his
hands but the use of this Opie spell is
restricted to the sacred rectangle of
power there's no frag or score limit the
timer is set at 45 minutes around
with two rounds being played though the
gym sometimes adds a few minutes each
round to account for mana breaks at the
end of the game the score from both
rounds is added together and the winner
is decided
usually a tied score is allowed but in
certain tournaments an extra two rounds
comprising the 15 minutes each are added
to the end of the match
if after that no team has a clear flag
capture advantage
each team elects its superior warriors
to take shots at the opposing teams tank
until one of them is defeated each game
is presided over by a mystical being
shrouded in black and red
a sort of power-mad mystic who conjures
new rules every game he disciplines
unruly play and hacking attempts by
distributing mystical yellow cards which
debuff players ability to tackle if any
player acquired two of these cards or a
single red card they are forced to
disconnect from the game and the squad
slot is left unfilled for the duration
of the game much like counter-strike if
the team loses five squad mates they are
forced to forfeit the game the mystic
also controls two flag bearing summons
who run up and down the map in line with
the flag these summons are responsible
for penalizing any players caught
camping in the opposing teams half if a
player is seen to be camping behind the
squad of defenders at the time the flag
is kicked towards them the game is
halted and the flag is automatically
returned to the opposing team the max
player cap is 22 we'd each server can
have anywhere from 0 to 80,000
spectators slots shirts shorts and socks
our standard and each player is required
to wear a pair of Greaves the tank wears
whatever the hell he wants
tactical injury and feigning death is
often employed but penalties for any of
these offenses are given at the whim of
the shrouded mystic foul language and
biting can result in a perma ban free
kicks or corner shots require the
defending team to set up a tower defense
strategy in order to regain possession
and once the endgame klaxon is sounded
teams exchange guild Tabard and
disconnect to their opposing team
lobbies and that's the game of soccer in
a nutshell thanks for watching to learn
about other sports in terms you
understand dial 1 900
Falls that's one 900 hot balls I've been
Bobby hey Laurie sports education expert
see you next time
to learn more about
Hertz and term that's that's Tim and
Eric Eric say spurts spirits hi there
I'm Bobby handler a sports education
expert in soccer
hey hey Pele spot me but did you know
that soccer is as a get with it those
intercut it I've been Bobby handler II
see you next time baby
you